handicapping the quarterback
competitions
for week one there are several
unsettled quarterback situations let's
begin
with the saints taysom hill jameis
winston when last we discussed it
winston was the betting favorite
courtesy of our friends at the points
bet sportsbook what percentage we don't
need to put odds on yeah okay
let's go we got a hundred total points
what percentage would you say it's gonna
be
hill versus what percentage would you
say it's going to be winston week one
starting quarterback green bay packers
coming to town i'm going to go 55 45
take some hill you know it's somewhere
in that range maybe 52 48 maybe it's
that maybe it's that close like that
type of thing but i feel like
taysom hill's you know the leader in the
leader house here okay as far as that's
concerned you know just in the fact of
hey he's been there with sean payton for
you know
a a pretty good number of years now
peyton loves him this was his project
he showed growth at the position two
years ago in preseason and of course
showed it last year and going three and
one
and you know wasn't the reason they lost
that game to philadelphia there's a lot
of things you can blame on that so i i'm
gonna go with that and the fact that
sean payton's gonna be
intrigued by the new attack on the
offensive side of the ball that he can
bring to the table with taysom hill
this is the dilemma for sean payton yeah
in
in one hand he has the guy
that he has crafted
slowly and meticulously the guy that he
has whittled right out of wood over the
course of five years he'll pick up that
piece of wood and he'll wear a little
more and he's created this beautiful
work of wooden
sculpture that is ready to go
meanwhile he's had this crash course
clay pot that he's that he's put
together
in jameis winston and it's every bit as
beautiful and he's got a chance to make
a better piece of art if he can reclaim
the career of the first overall pick in
the draft from 2015. and if you're sean
payton how do you choose between which
guy remember we said one of the factors
is going to be
how quickly can
hill or winston deal with
10 new plays yeah being thrown right
onto the onto the table the morning of
the game
who freaks out or who just says okay i
got this yeah i got this right you want
me to do this we'll do this it's
incorporated and off we go i just got a
feeling it's going to be winston you i
know you i've been feeling you you're
lean that way lately so like you're like
what are you going to do what you're
going to be your number if i do 50
would you say i'm going to go 52-48 i
think it's closer than my 55-45 initial
comment
i'm gonna go
52-48 the other way the other way i
think it's gonna be winston i think it's
100 we're not gonna know about it until
like three days before the game right
but you know the one the one factor for
me who's the defensive coordinator of
the packers now
oh joe berry yeah where'd he come from
he's been in tampa he's was the the the
rosie most recently uh the rams right he
was with the rebs in 2019
when jameis winston put 55 points up on
the board against the rams right 55
points 55 to 40 the rams won he was 28
for 41 385 yards four touchdown passes
one interception
um
i
you know
and and
hey look would i put a passion on peyton
to have
a revolving door
this and you know i've suggested this as
a relation to the patriots but maybe
sean payton would say i'm just going to
pick the guy each week that gives it the
best chance to win and you're going to
have to spend time preparing for both
guys
and you'll find out on friday who the
starter is team that we're about to play
good luck preparing to face the new
orleans saints this year yeah i i
wouldn't i wouldn't be shocked either
maybe especially early in the year
i i wouldn't i think both of these guys
can handle it maybe he would you know
have a little package for whoever the
backup is and you know bring it in to be
a curveball i wouldn't put anything by
buy him that way i would not um
yeah it's going to be you you really you
laid out a good case
what's that for week one week one week
packers right here comes joe berry
welcome welcome to your new job joe
berry here's a guy that put 55 points up
on your defense two years ago yeah no
it's a good thought it really is and we
know winston has the capabilities to be
a really special quarterback he does and
he's got more experience playing the
position of course uh taysom hill's got
some special qualities too but has not
played the position nearly as much as
jameis winston so
you know i think you're right to your i
like your point about you know being
able to handle offense or new things in
a hurry and hey we gotta i gotta throw
this in on a friday practice right now
and come on we got to get it and we got
to hit the ground running and practice
it and execute it all the right ways i
do think there's going to be you know uh
that'll be a big part of this
that's not a factor week one no it's not
later in the year as sean payton is
watching all the things happening around
the league looking for ideas constantly
churning and thinking and brainstorming
and being creative and that's when he
comes up with you know a handful of new
plays that somebody's got to figure out
how to run that'll be more relevant as
the season unfolds broncos teddy
bridgewater drew lock give me your
percentage there as to who the week one
starter is i clearly think there is a
higher upside with drew locke i really
do i think you have a chance to be a
much better football team and really
dangerous
if he can grow at that position and play
a little bit better and cleaner and not
be so overly aggressive in all of those
type of things
you know i gotta think he's got a little
bit
of an edge going into training camp and
those things but i mean it's my newt
because i would think a guy like vic
fangio is
you know right up i mean vic fangio like
a guy like him like teddy bridgewater is
right up his alley as far as the type of
quarterback you know okay he's not going
to make mistakes i know what he's gonna
do i can play defense manage the game
the right way and we'll win it that way
and listen defensive coaches in my
opinion think like that a little too
much at times to where i want to just go
man then it's just all about your
defense and managing the game you know
the quarterback's got to make some plays
i'm going to go with drew locke but it's
like i'm going to go 51-49 i i really
think this is one that will be settled
on the field preseason training camp and
will be closely watched i think this is
going to be a real a real tight one but
i'm going to give drew lock the slight
advantage
when vic fangio says hopefully we'll get
them a lot of pre-season snaps and the
decision will be made easy that to me
pushes the needle toward teddy
bridgewater because i think the things
that have kept drew lock from becoming
the guy that we thought he would be a
couple of years ago or will manifest
themselves in the preseason and make it
easier to say bridgewater i'm going to
go 60 40 bridgewater we're going to go
that's smarter yeah yeah okay
i know yeah i am it's a mike i i thought
about giving bridgewater to the
advantage too i guess in my heart of
hearts i feel like you do a little bit
that vic fangio is going to favor
bridgewater
i guess i'm playing the angle a little
bit of you know i don't know drew locke
has more of a talent to get the most out
of that talented offense and receivers
that's where i guess i i really struggle
with it but i see your point there and i
could see bridgewater really being in
the favor of that defensive minded head
coach
in new england for some reason pete has
put four names in front of me cam newton
mack jones jarrod stitt and brian hoyer
sorry stiderman hoyer you both get zeros
between jones and newton how do you
divide up the hundred percentage point
pi um i think i'm gonna go
like 80 20 here cam newton almost i i
don't think new england's the type of
place of course we both know this they
don't really want to play rookies no
matter how impressive they are
especially at quarterback you know i do
think new england's into the framing of
the team as we've talked about so much
cam is a strong voice and a great leader
for their team i do think they're
realistic about what happened with cam
newton last year and all those type of
things
um so i think that really it would take
a kind of a monumental
you know collapse or really horrible
play maybe a a a few games like we saw
from cam newton last year if he did that
again mac jones is coming in i can tell
you that if he starts throwing you know
one hoppers on 10 yard outs to receivers
and things like that we're going to see
mac jones but i think they're going to
do their best to let him stay on the
sideline develop and they'll ride it out
with cam one more year
they got three games before tommy comes
back to town yeah and i agree with you i
think it's going to be cam newton up
first i won't be surprised if we see
mack jones at some point in the first
three weeks as they decide who gives us
the best chance to beat brady in week
four and then try to build momentum
beyond that if they can beat brady in
the buccaneers i agree with you
i'll say 80 20 as well i may even go a
little higher than that i'll go 82
18.
math there pretty quickly pretty good
82-18
in the favor of cam newton andy dalton
justin fields in chicago sorry nick
foles dalton versus fields who's
starting when the bears go to la to play
the rams i'm gonna go 65-35
andy dalton but i feel like it's
something that can be chipped away at in
a hurry i do and out of all these guys
like you talked about about you know
implementing like a one guy into a
series or something like that to me this
is the one that makes like the most
sense hey andy dalton you start i think
we talked about this a little yesterday
or whatever hey andy dalton you start
the game oh hey we went down and scored
a touchdown hey you get another drive he
drives down again oh wait wait we went
six and out hey let's bring justin
fields in we got a little package of
plays for him to run the ball do some
things we've set up a game plan real
easy completion for him just to get
comfortable that way i i i would i think
i would err on
slowly and definitely indoctrinating him
into the game early on in the year and
then maybe if he got to a week three or
four then i start to go wait he's pretty
good he's running the ball really good
we've seen growth in the past and the
game's not too big for him and then
maybe you start to ride with justin
fields but come on we know what andy
dalton is and we know he's not the
future and let's get this guy ready the
number 11 pick of the draft i love
seeing the trains go by in the
background
practices it's awesome um
you know i i
maybe i should be fields in my view yeah
it should be it should be fields in my
view i i keep being
agitated by the matt nagy experience
with the chiefs in 2017 when my home sat
the whole year but i just think that
they're going to see that fields is
clearly better the things that made them
trade up to get fields will manifest
themselves on the practice field and i
think the locker room will be like what
the hell are we doing i think so too
sorry andy justin fields is the guy hey
ryan pace you were right to trade up
he's the guy let's go win with him mike
glennon got four starts in 2017 when
mitch trubisky was the second overall
pick i i just i don't think that helps
anybody so all right week one what are
you gonna put what's your number you're
gonna put like week because it's week
one i know like if you asked me week
five i probably would have changed that
number drastically and have been really
close but it's week one i'm gonna sit
right on 50 50. take that okay fine good
you sure you don't want to go
49.9 and you know 50 50. there is no
preponderance of the evidence all right
last one very quickly garoppolo
or trey lance oh your san francisco
49ers what did kyle tell you on sunday
about he told me they're coming out with
a whole new attack okay and you're never
kidding
george kittle at quarterback lance is
going to tight end actually it's it's a
shocking move no um
i mean as far as starting then being the
week one starter i mean i'm gonna go
similar to what i feel about the last
one to a degree i'm gonna go a little
stronger here and go 85 15 as far as
week one starter and all those type of
things yes maybe 90 10 jimmy garoppolo i
think trey lance will have to do
something extraordinary to get on the to
at least start week one or something
like that but i do think there's going
to be a package
you know for him too you know you trade
away three first-round picks there was
all this talk i just i have a hard time
thinking he's just gonna sit there on
the sidelines the whole time the whole
year that they're gonna get him used to
playing in football give the fans a
little taste of the number three pick of
the draft and all of that at least
that's how i see it playing out
i i still believe that all this chatter
about jimmy garoppolo is aimed at
getting trade value for him they're
going to hold out hope that somebody
somewhere tears an acl other than
garoppolo and they can unload garoppolo
in his contract onto them
if lance is the guy that they thought he
was when they made him the third overall
pick in the draft he should be the
starter week one and uh i think that the
rest of this stuff is just noise it's bs
it's posturing i'm gonna go
80 20 lance okay wow going strong there
i mean listen i i don't think your
thoughts crazy there i don't i have no
absolutely no feel for what my buddy's
doing here or thinking or anything okay
as i've stated many times before we stay
away from these type of conversations we
do he doesn't want to tell me because i
got a big mouth i'm going to say it on
tv so i don't know but we'll see and uh
i know i'm i'm i'm fa i i think you
could be right though maybe yes if
somebody did tear their acl and they
felt like wait lance has really come
along and he feels comfortable they
might just go screw it see you jimmy g
we're trading you and we're riding with
the number three pick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports